j'ai bien envie de vous parler de sous
vêtements pour la première fois les
hommes ont leur place au salon
international de la lingerie porte de
versailles alors que vous le savez la
consommation féminine est en pleine
envolée caroline since à vérifier que la
lingerie masculine était un créneau
porteur
c'est une revendication
on peut être simple naturelle direct et
être un homme et donc être aimable et
c'est vrai que dieu merci on n'est plus
à l'époque du match aux bobos et qu'on
est arrivé à d qui existait déjà mais on
est arrivé à dire que l'intuition n'est
pas forcément une qualité et féminine et
la force pas forcément une qualité
masculine et oui maintenant les
créateurs et donc les publicitaires est
aussi les hommes depuis moins d'un an
les mâles sont à la fiche en slips
caleçons ou string changement de
mentalité le sous vêtement n'est plus
l'apanage des femmes
attention ça va faire mal il ya un petit
bébé dans cette campagne et 10 ans et
leur répondre comme pour les hommes et
les femmes ont fait pas des enfants tout
seuls
donc ces hommes qui sont tout seuls ils
font des enfants on sait bien avec thil
et le débit il est tout nu laitonnés
bien évidemment je sais on parle d'un
truc de base qui est quand même un slip
en caleçon
et là le jeu c'est que ces hommes
plaisent aux hommes et aux femmes
c'est ça le jean alors comment plaire
aux hommes et aux femmes nous sommes
allés au salon de la lingerie et
découvrir les dessous chics et choc des
mal nouveaux amateurs de qu'elles sont
sachez que vous êtes une minorité
seuls 10% des hommes emportent en 88
qu'il s'allonge et il moule les
tendances retour au style kangourou et
puis la grenouillère ou le soigne le
maillot de nos arrière grands pères le
mâle 88 le mal des années 30 revu et
corrigé
alors pour conclure ce reportage est
quand même demander l'avis d'un homme
rova le caméraman qu'on ne voit jamais
d'habitude ils choisissent aux prises un
slip très classique romain met ainsi en
soyant licra et puis le reste de
l'équipe est derrière en string alors à
bouger rare qu'est ce que vous préférez
le caleçon le string ou le slip tout
simple moi je suis resté caroline très
couches culottes parfaite